uh and instead anticipating this jordan
has actually sacrificed a pawn automatic
recapture i assumed would happen but no
he pushes forward and this is really
clever actually from the dutchman
because now he's opening up his bishops
and i think we'll see magnus start
shaking his head because now after a
trade here
all of black's pieces have improved
their quality this bishop hitting this
pawn this bishop kind of got its laser
vision along this diagonal and also the
black rook becoming super active so
jordan we talked about how he likes to
sacrifice pawns he's been working with
daniel dubois remember as part of
magnus's training camp dubov the
ultimate pawn sacrificer and suddenly
black has the better pieces and look at
that the evaluation bar is forced to
keep an eye on the pawn on h5 the rook
is not going anywhere by itself
it needs teamwork and of course the rick
is also tied down to the defense of the
light squared ones so i just think
they're going to repeat moves yeah and
white is never going to run out of moose
and reach something we call zugswang
where every move white makes would work
worse in his position because he can
wait with the king or with a bishop
and okay this is the second time we've
seen this position we're about to get
the draw there we go magnus miraculously
holds i'm shaking his head magnus
crossing eventually though after being
in big trouble he saves the draw against
jordan forest